Good news, Amazon Prime subscribers: September
2019 brings plenty of westerns, two Mad Max
films, gateways to the stars, presidents fighting
terrorists in the sky, kaiju and Arnold Schwarzenegger
breaking faces on Mars.
Here's the best of what's ahead.
The edgy action-drama series The Family Man
stars the renowned Indian actor Manoj Bajpayee
as an undercover operative who works for a
government intelligence agency trying to take
down terrorist groups from the inside.
The Family Man looks not only at the danger
he faces working for the government, but how
he balances that work with his demanding family
life.
In August 2019, India West reported The Family
Man was the first Indian television series
to be showcased by Los Angeles' Television
Critics Association.
The first season is 10 episodes long, and
is directed by a dynamic duo known as "Raj
and DK."
They've made a name for themselves in Bollywood
directing quirky sleepers like the 2011 crime
drama Shor in the City and the 2013 zombie
comedy Goa Goa Gone.
Amazon Prime doesn't have a firm release date
for the series premiere, but we know it'll
be available in September.
Starring Rosa Salazar of Alita: Battle Angel
fame and Bob Odenkirk of Better Call Saul,
Amazon Prime's Undone is a unique animated
series about a woman whose sense of reality
suffers a seismic shift after a car crash.
Salazar's Alma wakes in her hospital bed to
find her dead father Jacob, played by Odenkirk,
waiting for her.
As the series unfolds, Alma's father reveals
she's experiencing time in a new, non-linear
way, and he teaches her to use it so she can
solve the mystery of who killed him in the
hopes she can eventually go back in time to
prevent his murder.
Undone will be ready to blow your mind Friday,
September 13th.
And now for a look at some of the best movies
coming to Prime in September, starting with
the best action flicks on offer.
Most of the television series added to Amazon
Prime's streaming service in September will
be original content like Undone and The Family
Man, with the notable exception of American
Horror Story: Apocalypse the eighth season
of the popular FX horror anthology series.
Apocalypse begins with, true to its name,
a nuclear apocalypse.
The series' stars are left in a decimated
world they have to learn to survive.
See how or if they learn to cope on September
24th.
September on Amazon Prime features car chases
at the end of the world, gunsmoke, epic duels,
and an American president beating up Gary
Oldman on a plane.
All of the best action films are added to
Prime on the same day Monday, September 30th.
At the end of July, George Miller revealed
there are multiple sequels to 2015's Mad Max:
Fury Road in development.
But if you're more a fan of the original films
starring Mel Gibson as the post-apocalyptic
tough guy, Amazon Prime adds 1981's Mad Max
2: The Road Warrior and 1985's Mad Max Beyond
Thunderdome to its library.
If you like your future action flicks with
at least a little less apocalypse, Arnold
Schwarzenegger gets his butt to Mars in 1990's
trippy action classic Total Recall.
"If I'm not me, then who the hell am I?"
Meanwhile, Kurt Russell and James Spader star
in the film that spawned a whole host of television
spinoffs 1994's Stargate.
On the same day, Harrison Ford stars as President
James Marshall who's kidnapped by the vengeful
Gary Oldman in 1997's Air Force One, and Jon
Travolta and Nicolas Cage assume each others'
identities in the John Woo classic Face/Off.
Even though Halloween won't be for another
month, Amazon Prime isn't wasting any time
in going for the screams.
September 30th will see a long list of horror
and thriller flicks added to Prime's streaming
library.
If you enjoy your chills with a dash of science
fiction, there's 1997's Event Horizon starring
Laurence Fishburne and Sam Neill.
In early August we learned Death Note director
Adam Wingard was tapped to direct an upcoming
TV series based on the film, so here's your
chance to check out the source material.
For more earthbound terrors, there's 2008's
Cloverfield, following a group of friends
trying to survive a giant monster attack in
New York City.
If you're more interested in thrillers rooted
in the real world, there's 2002's Insomnia.
Directed by Christopher Nolan, Insomnia tells
the story of a sleep-deprived detective played
by Al Pacino who accidentally shoots and kills
his own partner while pursuing suspected killer
Walter Finch, played by Robin Williams.
Prime's library will also include a number
of excellent psychological thrillers at the
end of September, including 1999's The Talented
Mr. Ripley starring Matt Damon and Gwyneth
Paltrow and 2003's Gothika starring Halle
Berry and future Iron Man Robert Downey Jr.
"I suggest that we simply increase the medication
until things start to make sense."
"Or maybe until I can get myself a new doctor."
For more dramatic fare, Amazon Prime's September
30th offerings bring war, thunder, ghosts
and grit.
Ethan and Joel Cohen's excellent 2010 remake
of 1969 classic True Grit will be available
for streaming, starring Jeff Bridges as the
drunken curmudgeon Rooster Cogburn, and Hailee
Steinfeld as the young Mattie Ross.
For an epic much closer chronologically to
our own time, there's Oliver Stone's Vietnam
War saga Platoon, starring Charlie Sheen and
an incredible ensemble cast, including Willem
Dafoe.
If you're excited about the upcoming sequel
no one was expecting, Top Gun: Maverick, you
might be able to satisfy your cravings a bit
with the 1990 sports action drama Days of
Thunder starring Tom Cruise as stock car racer
Cole Trickle and Nicole Kidman as Trickle's
neurosurgeon love interest Claire.
If you want something without so much car
racing or war, there's 2001's black comedy
drama Ghost World, starring Thora Birch, Steve
Buscemi, and future Avenger Scarlett Johansson.
"You just hate every single guy on the face
of the Earth."
"That's not true.
I just hate all these extroverted, pseudo-bohemian
losers."
"You guys up for some reggae tonight?"
There isn't a lot of comedy on its way to
Amazon Prime in September, but what is coming
is interesting — and it all drops on September
30th.
Prime may be one of the few places you'll
be able to see 1994's Trading Mom.
Starring Sissy Spacek of Carrie fame and Anna
Chlumsky of My Girl and Veep, Trading Mom
is about a trio of siblings who cast a spell
on their nagging mother to make her disappear.
For a comedy fantasy that's a bit more recent,
there's 2008's Ghost Town, starring Ricky
Gervais in his first leading film role as
a dentist who can see and communicate with
ghosts.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.